[Music]
you nearly blew my ears off sister
you went just a little close how's it
going absolutely wonderfully what a
lovely
cuddly teddy bear jumper you're wearing
they say blue and green should never be
seen except on an irish queen oh right
you look fine i i don't subscribe to the
whole blue and green thing i think you
look great
um but very cuddly i'm sure when you get
home tonight your wife will say i'll
give it a cuddle in that jumbo i should
probably just take the jumper office
won't put it on herself
maybe that's better oh you mean taker
hey
oh i see you're wearing some shoes from
the future again moon boots i think
these are uh like uh
i think these are lebron james those are
fantastic good aren't they yeah really
nice well done nike as they say in the
states or nike as they say in
britain and i like my advertising to be
not
front row subtle most of the time
although i say subtle this is obviously
a
mickey mouse disney t-shirt which i'm
quite emblazoned well should we jump
into a few uh voicemails people have
been sending us i would love to hear
many voicemails i'd like to hear some
voices on the friendship onions before
we do i had a question for you bills oh
hold on hold on everyone i want to make
some notes right just think about this
right because i'll write down your
answer
i've
i've approached you with a cherry
hmm
you can take it to the bank that the
cherry has been cleaned it's clean as a
whistle
it's an organic cherry
it's ripe it's red
i give it to you
what do you do next think about it
before you answer
billy boyd
cherry answer
first off yeah i would thank you for the
cherry thanks for the cherry
yeah
i would look at the cherry look
okay
just look at it with both eyes both eyes
look at the cherry
after thanking
me
for that for the cherry thanking me for
the cherry yeah
and then i would smell the cherry smell
the cherry
olfactory
area of answer
smell the cherry then i would lock eyes
with you look me directly in the eye and
without breaking that yeah
i would place a cherry in my mouth
break off
i'd break off the stem break off the
stem where's that stem going
are you holding on to it while you well
the cherries still in your mouth i think
i'm putting it in my breast pocket stem
i'll put that in parentheses in brackets
stem in breast pocket
yeah brilliant
i would suck all the flesh off of the
seed you've got some strength in your
tongue
suck
the cherry i'm gonna i'm gonna
uh underline that
because i think that's the meat of the
meat
and the meat of the cherry fruit the
flesh until the the
would you call it the piss
[Laughter]
are you saying suck my skin off no i'd
see the it's just this seeds it's left
left yeah with virtually no flesh on it
yeah
yeah
where's that going
you're not gonna don't say you're gonna
swallow it do not no i would never
swallow it
i would
breast pocket breast pocket back with
the stem
so the stem
and the
cherry
we'll call it the pit is it a cherry pit
yeah see
cherry seed
in your breast pocket yeah fruit in your
stomach yeah does that be right yeah by
that time fruit in stomach that's
brilliant bills no worries thanks for
that
no problem thank you for the cherry
you're welcome all right well let's go
with some voicemails fantastic
[Music]
dom billy love the show it's the only
podcast i've listened to
seriously it's fantastic and
despite being successful actors you guys
come across as
salt of the earth type of people and i
think the
friendship onion is really just what the
world needs
that being said
i've got a small gripe with your eat the
world segment
i'm going to need you guys to take about
20 offer when you're chewing on the
microphone especially you dumb
hearing your tongue and your lip smack
around while you're trying to say mass
decay with a full mouth it's one of the
grossest things i experience on a
regular basis
and i've got two really small kids so i
spent a decent amount of my spare time
dealing with baby [ __ ] throw up
i mean i can literally feel the spit
travel through the microphone across the
country and out of my phone speaker to
trip on me in massachusetts
all right
love you guys
massachusetts
brilliant willian i told you dom that
gentleman did not give his name do we
know his name anyway that lovely
gentleman nameless he shall remain
famous but he's from massachusetts made
a solid point now i've i've
put my foot in both camps to be honest
i'll have i've had people in in my
instagram
say please don't chew as much it's
disgusting and then i've had other
people saying i love the chewing stuff
it's very funny i don't i'm not sure
maybe i'll just back off the mic a
little bit i think we can see that the
country is divided
as everyone is saying and it's through
um how much do you want to hear someone
masticate yeah let us know if you have
any strong opinions about how much or
little billionaire chew during billion
dollar meet the world yep
here is another a voicemail hey billion
donald this is zach collin from reno
nevada i have a quick question about the
first scene where we're introduced to
mariadoc brandybuck and peregrine tuk
which of course is the 111th birthday
party of bilbo baggins
i have a question about the scene where
you lift that wonderful dragon firework
up off of the ground in the tent
we see the firework coming up from the
ground and then of course i'm sure cgi
takes over but i was curious what kind
of special effects went into the uh the
stunt work or the props work or whatever
for that firework
huge fan of the podcast can't wait to
hear your answer thanks bye
that was a really fun day if you
remember
it was in a studio in wellington
in a sound stage
and they did set up the firework inside
the um tent
and it was on a sort of piece of um
fish wire or whatever you call it yeah
so you can't see the wire and then the
firework did have some
gunpowder in it so it did make a noise
and it flashed and then someone shot it
up so the first sort of six feet of it
going up in the air was going to happen
and then we cut
and the makeup girls did a brilliant job
of like you know blackening our face
with suit and putting our hair up to the
point that i thought this is too much
i thought pete's going to say no that's
not it am i writing thinking he asked
for more i think so yeah i think we went
away to go to the makeup trailer to do
it and the makeup girls said scrunch up
your face so it looks like you're
getting ready for an explosion we had
all these really fun crow's feet i seem
to remember we went to pete and you and
i were like the the knockouts he's going
to get us to wash our face and he
laughed and said more more yeah and and
that's when they back combed her hair up
and it was a brows a really funny day
but as i say the firework did go up
about six feet and we did it
a couple of times in rehearsal
and then we went to film it and when
they filmed it that's when they set fire
to the the gun powder and it made the
noise and the light and it really did
give me a freight and so that scream
that's on um
on the scene is actually streaming yeah
yeah and what i was going to say about
the oh and i was going to say the great
way that pete filmed it and then chose
to edit that sequence was that you
obviously do see mary and pippin you see
them
behind the back of
gandalf's cart taking the firework and
you see them
you know working out who's going to
light it and all that kind of stuff but
you never fully see them in a great big
juicy close-up until they're covered in
black and the hair's all back combed and
the great thing about that is the
audience immediately know these two are
troublemakers that's who they are these
two are going to be characters and then
you see us washing the pots with gandalf
and the other thing washing the pots
with gandalf was a forced perspective of
that yeah so you and i were washing
dishes next to each other
and gandalf was much closer to the
camera yeah looking to his right we were
looking to our left but to our left was
nothing and gandalf was about yeah 10 12
feet ahead of us yeah great day amazing
that was great
thanks
uno mas
c
very good dumb
espanol
very good hey my name is diana and i'm
from portugal and i just read a lot of
the rings for the first time last year
and i'm so glad i did it because i met
such good people like you too
and i was wondering do you think that
your friendship would be this strong if
you didn't met through lord of the rings
is your friendship just a result of
living through that period together or
do you think that you two would actually
be very good friends anyway if you met
through another context not just working
together thank you for your podcast and
bye bye
it's a good question that dom it's a
tough one to call really because it's
hard isn't it because you've got to sort
of imagine a different life
sliding doors yeah exactly
um
i would reckon
we would probably be friends
however we met
but just going through that length of
time and this sort of real adventure
that that was
sort of solidified that and put us in
places and times
that we might never have done so now we
have those shared memories that make it
easier now yeah yeah i mean people ask
us all the time did you guys know each
other before lord of the rings i think a
lot of people are always quite surprised
that we didn't but we obviously met in
new zealand i think like you said maybe
if we'd have met
in another
adventure adventurous tumultuous time
maybe we did a play that went on the
road for
nine months and it was either a great
success or it was really tough to do
something that forges a friendship i
think it probably would have been harder
if let's say you and i were ships
passing in the night on a show
you did a month added a couple of weeks
and we were like oh hey that was fun but
didn't really know each other would be
harder
because
even with the people that we might
not be as close to
uh from rings as you and i are like
david wenham or john noble or hugo who
we had a great time with but we just
don't see that much
when you see them there still is that
little thing right yeah we did that
together yeah group this gang
together
and it just so happens that you and i
have lived in the same cities for a long
amount of time yeah so yeah
there you go good question i'm glad you
read lord the rings lovely yeah
fantastic um
we also have some emails here so let's
get straight into these go on tom this
from nick in nottingham
knockout
my wonderful cousin lucy lives hi luce
um
he says hey guys loving the podcast you
guys are great to listen to in the
evening oh that's sweet i have a tricky
hypothetical question for you both if
you could only listen to music from one
decade for the rest of your life what
decade would it be and nick said for him
he would listen to the 1970s any strong
thoughts or feelings there i have very
strong thoughts about that good no nick
i'd like to know how old nick is
because i think most people would go
back to the decade
of
when they were around 15 years old
so for me
i would i would do the decade of the 80s
but as someone who who likes to make
music and goes into studios and i like
tape machines and compressors and
musical things and i think they nailed
that in the 70s
i think 70s music
if you're an audiophile
is that right i think so
p-h-i-l-e if you like listening to music
in a kind of a quality i think 70s music
sounds the best right but as a type of
music i would listen to the 80s because
that's when i was growing up and it was
that's the music that really influenced
me the most so if i had to choose the
1980s
great answer uh
and i agree with a lot of what you said
there the formative years in music tends
to be you know those kind of 15 16 17
years
um
but it's also like
almost every era becomes cool again
right there was a point where 80s music
was like oh the 80s that's so naff and
then the eighties came back and then
people were like oh the 70's disco
that's good enough and then disco came
back then the 90s had a period where it
came out so it all kind of goes around
in a in a circle
so it's if you could only listen to one
decade for the rest of your life
i might go 80s as well you know
because
you can find great i mean obviously i'm
such a fan of the beatles which is
much more 60s
but then i like george michael well you
look and madonna i like madonna
i know you like madonna i like david
bowie i know you like david
and he jumps over so many as they all do
but he jumps over so many different
areas you've got
70s
bowie or bowie but then 80s bowie is
quite interesting and even 90s and even
i mean that last album they did black
star which was like
i don't know he says this isn't
answering the question the 1980s
i'll read you one here you're ready
maggie m from salt lake city says utah
if you could bring one animal species
back from extinction
what would it be and why oh great
question now before you answer this have
you seen jurassic park
the documentary yeah yeah
so that was scary isn't it there i
wouldn't go no and they probably
shouldn't have brought those animals
back should they no you can't go that to
that island now no they've closed it all
down they're all all the t-rexes every
couple stuff every couple of years they
open it back up and make another
documentary right but um not seeing the
other docks right
i would bring back
because for me i always think well what
would have the most amount of
and a global
effect
on things that you're trying to improve
in the natural world like conservation
or
bringing back an animal that would be
the symbol of conservation or maybe an
important animal in
an area like a jungle or a forest or a
desert an ocean so for me yep it's two
things really
either the woolly mammoth because i
think bringing back a massive woolly
elephant bigger than an elephant would
be such a huge moment for people to
witness that maybe they'd change their
ideas about elephant poaching and maybe
maybe they changed their ideas about
animal in general so that would have a
massive
wow effect and then the other thing
is you know the thylacine the tasmanian
tiger from australia right kind of a
strange looking slightly
slightly hairless dog with stripes like
a zebra right yeah incredible looking
they went extinct in the late 1900s
again that's an animal that if you saw
it you'd go oh my word that's incredible
so
probably the mammoth if i had to choose
one i think that's a good one yeah
you obviously have a greater knowledge
than me and all their stuff
yeah you do
but i don't even know if this is a true
story but i heard the dodo is extinct
because
humans arrived on an island and
basically at the mall yeah they're like
a turkey like a slow-moving turkey can
we bring those back because it's a shame
that we just arrived and basically ate
them all so quickly they couldn't
yeah they couldn't stay alive i believe
it was one of the islands in the cook
straits in the journey that captain cook
took
and yeah and once they got off the boat
they had exhausted the supplies on the
boat yeah and they didn't have birds on
the boat
suddenly they're in a place that's full
of slow-moving stupid
birds that can that can't fly
or can kind of fly a little bit like a
chicken maybe just
and then they're done and they were like
well we've just eaten all of these in a
bounty here so they wiped them out the
other thing is that when you go to
islands that are isolated that like the
galapagos that has very little to do
with humans they've not learned that
humans are dangerous so yeah you can
approach the mcgreen marine iguanas in
the galapagos or the tortoises and they
just don't know that you're a threat
until they learn which is a very sad
yeah kind of uh
reflection on the human species
bring back the door door
john
i'll tell you how i like to start my day
now and i did it just there
i started with a nice glass of liquid
ivy
because you've got to be hydrated dom
flu season is in full swing proper
hydration vitamins very very important
one stick of liquid iv and 16 ounces of
water hydrates you faster and more
efficiently than water alone that's an
incredible fact and also like you said
we're moving into the time of year where
you're getting coughs and sniffles and
his flu season so a little dose of
vitamin c and all your other vitamins go
a long way first thing in the morning i
like to wake up have a liquid iv on an
empty stomach it's great after a workout
as i said it's good when you're feeling
down if you're having a couple of
holiday drinks it's quite good as a
hangover cure and they have a fantastic
give back mission they've donated over
11 million sticks to people all around
the world
and it's clean ingredients dom
non-gmo vegan free of gluten dairy and
soy grab your favorite liquid iv flavors
nationwide at walmart or you can get 25
off when you go to liquid iv.com and use
the code onion check out that's 25
off anything you order when you get
better hydration today using promo code
onion at liquidive.com
dom
getting older
a little bit older is not always easy
there's some things that come with that
that aren't much fun one
hair loss
a lot of men
get hair loss as they get older and i
don't like it but there's ways that we
can help isn't there tom billy there is
and i think you're talking about keeps
now two out of three men will experience
some sort of hair loss by the time
they're 35 and keeps offers a simple
stress-free way to keep your hair you
get convenient virtual doctor
consultations and medications delivered
straight to your door every three months
you don't even need to leave your own
home and um it can be very low cost
treatments start at just ten dollars a
month and they offer generic versions
and discrete packaging so if you don't
want people to know that you might be
going a little bit bald they'll never
know with this packaging dom if you're
ready to take action and prevent hair
loss go to k e e p s dot com slash onion
to receive your first month of treatment
for free that's k e e p s dot com slash
onion to get your first month free
k e e p s dot com
slash
well that was fantastic good question
sale tom speaking of music really
well join me in the chorus if you
recognize this right go
hold on
just because i'm feeling this song and
we've been talking about it you'll know
it
you'll be good here we go
i'll put both my cans on so i can hear
me in stereo
do you want the lights done do you okay
i don't know if they can do that
just carry on then travis is shaking he
said don't make me didn't like it here
we go
still don't know what i was
waiting for i'm at times
running wild in the dead in streets and
every time i thought i'd got it made it
seemed the taste was not so sweet
hang on
so i just turned myself to face me
that's good done yourself but i never
caught a glimpse
nothing
all the others must see the faker
but
we must do fast to take that test
a perfect rendition of changes by uh
david sorry if it was too loud you guys
it took a long time to get to the chorus
david bowie likes he likes to build he's
just he's a slow build there's a great
moment in uh hunky dory arguably my
favorite
bowie album it's a song called queen
[ __ ]
at the end of the album and it's one of
the greatest starts to a song ever
where it's just a cappella and he goes
so good well worth listening to here's a
little studio thing on how he used to
record when you said um
sorry if that was too loud do you know
what he would have he'd have his vocal
mic here right but then he'd have
another vocal mic behind and then when
he was singing and it went to the loud
man it'd pick up on that one
and the closer one would cut out of
course it wasn't cut out so he had this
sort of mix of a further away mic and a
closer mic probably could sound like
this
i wonder if that's what happened with
changes
changes
he went
and it was too loud and he went over
there
anyway well bills it's time for what we
hope is going to be a regular feature of
the show yes
which we're now calling quirky working
we're calling it quirky working let's
explain to people at home what quirky
work he is well we want people who
listen or watch the show to write in and
we could maybe discuss
uh
a strange job that they have a career
yeah that might be out of the ordinary
quirky working working working a novel
job weird work yeah any of those type of
crazy careers and with that in mind
we're bringing in tim price who i
believe is a manc union is that right
tim oh
uh almost i'm from sheffield but i do
live in manchester now
sheffield sheffield pope jarvis country
yorkshire man is he also from sheffield
oh he's from sheffield i feel united um
pope
i think for my money pope won
the battle of brit pop everyone was
talking about blur and oasis and polk
just kind of scooped in with the best
out yeah just on this side just you know
i'm just playing it cool i absolutely
love jarvis [ __ ] i'd love to meet him
one day yeah
you know how everyone says
well i've seen him oh nice that counts
it's very tall that does
yes it does tim he was on a stage but
you know oh he's much much taller than
them
i'll tell you what they did
when i went to see pulp as the first
song
it was great where i couldn't even
remember what song it was and jarvis is
up there doing his thing
and then at the end of the first song
jarvis cocker came on
like so he's already on stage and then
he walked on it was like something from
like the black mirror or something
they'd got the guy do you remember the
show stars in their eyes stars in their
eyes were people that pretended to be
and they had such a great jarvis cocker
that jarvis cocker got him on to the
stage at glasgow and he sang the first
song it was so weird because everybody's
gone crazy and then jarvis cocker walks
on oh that's brilliant yeah it was great
thrill that must have been for the guy
from stars and for me oh yeah for you i
enjoyed it yeah
all right well tim why don't you tell us
what your quirky work he is
well i i was listening to the podcast a
few weeks ago where dom you mentioned
which uh primary school you went to yeah
saying winifred's and it yeah and it
rang a bell immediately because it's
just around the corner for my work oh
well i thought i'd email in what did you
work just on disney road
yeah yeah just off it yeah right nice
and and can you just corroborate because
i still think billy doesn't believe me
that saint winifred's was is quite a
famous school isn't it because that's
the school where they they sang they had
some hits in the
in the chat yeah just
some top of the pop sort of stuff yeah
yeah
and then a follow-up i totally believe
that that's that school
i just don't believe that you went there
i only went there for a year the last
year from germany but i did go there
they were very talented
we love you
grandma
we do
too is oh yeah i went about i was being
the thing i was being one of the
teachers there it was hillary yeah nuns
we were taught by nuns but you taught by
nuns when you were um younger no never
met a nun really to think so uh i know a
few girls i went to school with who are
nuns now really and i know a nun who
went on the run really like the movie
she was a criminal mum ask me how many
nuns i've met how many nuns have you met
none
the nuns that taught me yeah i would
think they've probably uh passed over
now well it's a while back sister
margarita and sister acquirers well i'll
just say this and then we'll leave it
there right i don't think they went up
oh dear i think the two of them went
well believe it or not just leave it or
draw a line under that tip i don't know
anyway we digress
what do you do yes what do you do what
is your crazy career your wacky work
my wacky uh workie is i make lasers for
a living
laser beams
laser beams
what are you doing i've got a lot of
questions
but i mean your first one for what what
are the lasers used for
um so we send them out to sort of a lot
of universities uh i don't know what
they use them for but the big one we use
them for is uh for dna sequencing that's
sort of our biggest biggest seller we
the lasers the lasers i made go into
systems
they do some dna sequencing that's the
biggest seller that's brilliant
have you ever have you ever sold any
pink floyd
is that a different kind of laser uh
back in the day the company actually
started as sort of uh you know like the
disco laser
yeah before moving into the scientific
stuff so yeah so maybe back in the day
that's brilliant
but wait a minute now how do you even
go about making let's talk what a laser
is
first off yeah it's an acronym right
laser is it light yeah
light and sago
and rybina are you sure no
yeah close uh light amplification by the
stimulated emission of radiation
stands for that you were very close
so
a laser is light
but why is it different from like a 30
watt bulb good question thank you yeah
um so what makes the laser difference
from light is sort of sort of free
properties it's only one color
if you look up like a light bulb in the
ceiling that's giving off a load of
different wavelengths which is why you
sort of see it as a white light yeah a
laser will only give off one color
another thing it's all coherent as in if
you imagine uh
waves of light yeah
they all sort of match up with each
other at the same time
so then the other one it right carries
it
the other one is collimated so sort of
uh goes in a straight line basically all
this sort of uh
all powered into a small area all going
into a straight line
so it's only one color because it's only
got one wavelength is that right uh yeah
so the the wavelengths that admit is
such a small little section it only
sends out one color and is it always the
same color
oh no i do a few different colors me
what's your favorite color the ones oh i
would say we do a lovely shade of blue
oh it's my favorite color blue i like a
lecture of like a
oh yeah like a lightsaber blues oh
that's my favorite color is that the
good guys and star star wars but
generally yeah i would say the good guys
okay
and then all right
but yeah we do red and green uh we do uh
infrared ones that you can't even see
why why would you say yellow why would
you want an infrared one for it is it
for like clubs that are like yes
and no this would be for more scientific
stuff cool stuff
can you yeah you know
can a laser burn through anything like
in the movies
um i can tell you can burn through uh
the sleeve on your lab coat pretty
quickly oh well it will it just like
really yeah
yeah when i'm uh making them is my big
uh floor is my uh the sleeves of my lab
coat often get caught in the beams and
if you can smell a bit of burning in the
lab that'll just be me singeing my
clothes
wow so it can be quite a dangerous job
uh oh yeah if it goes anywhere near your
eyes yeah
and the thing they did on the first day
was show us a training video of this a
laser beam hitting a just like an
eyeball and it just sort of
ah
who volunteered to have their eyes shot
through with a laser just and three
takes it took as well oh wow
no
haven't been gone i say this is really
interesting nicely insane i can see
because we
you know it's not all
laughs and fun here by the way we've
spoken to brian green and everything we
talk about
string theory yeah we love all that
stuff education manila stuff so i
remember when i get taught about lasers
in school
the teacher said to us so if you've got
a perfect laser and you fired it at the
moon
the the size of the beam would be the
same
where it fired from to when it got to
the moon you know like light dissipates
is it yeah yeah so it's a laser just
always stays the same
uh
yeah you can have that but that's like
incredibly hard to achieve most of them
sort of
veer off slightly so they get slightly
bigger right so it does start only
slightly there yeah the aim is to to uh
stop that as much as possible try and
get it you know as parallel going in a
straight line wow
how big's the facility in which you make
lasers tim
we've got about 150 200 people
okay so very big so lasers are really
and basically so that people can find
out what breed of dog they have
it's all about just looking back at dna
and saying yeah it's definitely a poodle
that is the biggest
or something like that shoe with laser
the labrador gets shot off with some
parts the poodle might get shot for
different parts
that's crazy what an interesting so how
do you go about making a a laser
uh so for me i'm sort of in the
production side so imagine uh sort of
like a meccano set right i would say
it's close to something like that i'm
sort of putting together
uh i'm adjusting lenses i'm putting in
mirrors uh sort of aligning everything
to like
so we're in like
meters there's a little twist here and
there
and if i do it right a laser beam should
shoot out the hole in the front of the
box
goodness me
that's amazing isn't it what and what's
your favorite thing about your job tim
well well you do get to play with lasers
every day so i mean
i mean i mean that's what you really
play with lasers you get to yeah you
definitely come to the right place right
were you always into
lasers like were you fascinated by
lasers growing up
um so yeah i was big into physics as a
kid but i actually did maths at uni and
i got
this job through a friend
who was at this laser place and he was
like do you want to have a go i was like
of course i would have ago wow how long
you been doing it now
uh
nearly five years i've been there now
nice wait so you studied what like
higher maths at university like you have
a degree in mathematics
yeah so yeah i've got a degree in maths
what's 13 plus eight
sorry what's that what's 13 plus 8.
did you say 21
yeah it's 20 it is just 21. he's
obviously a math genius
billy i'll give you a little top tip for
your post workout protein shake are you
ready go on i put my protein shake in
the blender a little bit of ice a little
bit of water but what i'm doing now is
i'm adding
three or four little spoonfuls of magic
spoon cereal and my favorite flavor to
put in there is the peanut butter so you
get a nice little
boost of extra protein with your protein
shake well listen to this dom
if you do that you know that you are
getting zero grams of sugar 13 to 14
grams of protein and only four net grams
of carbs in each serving and dom
only 140 calories a serving
i'll go even better it's keto friendly
it's gluten free it's grain free it's
soy free and it's low carb and you can
build your own box available flavors to
build from in your own custom bundle are
cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter my
particular favorite blueberry cinnamon
cookies and creams
lovely and you can you can mix it up any
way you want healthy yet delicious
perfect for guiltless midnight snacks
so go to magicspoon.com
onion to grab a custom bundle of cereal
and try it today and be sure to use the
promo code onion at checkout to save
five dollars off your order
and magic spoon is so confident in their
product it's packed with a hundred
percent happiness guarantee so if you
don't like it for any reason they'll
refund your money no questions asked
remember get your next delicious box of
guilt-free cereal at magicspoon.com
onion and use the code onion to save
five dollars thank you magic spoon for
sponsoring this episode
between all the trolls and dragons it's
important to have the right insurance in
middle earth but comparing insurance
companies online can take longer than
talking to an ent that is where the
zebra comes in
with the zebra you can compare karen
home quotes from every major insurance
company in under five minutes giving you
all the facts you need to make the right
decision it's the fastest way to find
the right coverage at the right price
and
we'll help you find a provider that you
can trust in fact the zebra saves people
on average
922 dollars a year on home and auto
combined and now by your flagging of the
only brew for the brave and true from
your local green dragon
billy i've had some nightmares over the
years with insurance companies i've
called one i've got a quote on my car
i've got a quote on my uh you know
holiday insurance i've got a quote on my
house i've said can you hang on a second
i'll get back to you then i call another
company they give me a different quote
is it cheaper is it more expensive it's
so confusing at times but the zebra
makes it as simple as they can
save time and money in minutes compare
quotes for free at the zebra.com onion
that's at the zebra.com slash onion
just to quickly touch upon where you
live since that is kind of you know
where i grew up from
11 until 18.
um not to give you your full home
address or anything like that to him but
do you live in and around stockport the
heatons type way
uh i i did live in the heatons but now
i've moved over to charlton oh sure and
okay yeah i have friends in charlotte do
you
i used to live in heaton moore did you
have a favorite pub in the heaton's when
you were there oh yeah yeah so there was
the plow on the mall i love the plow
there was the ground the elizabeth
elizabeth and that's where i met liam
gallagher well done yeah oh yeah there's
a lot of stories about the galagas and
the elizabeth yeah i remember a very
surreal moment just as definitely maybe
was like cresting that wave
liam gallagher was hanging out with with
quite a few people including me and my
mates and they just brought out the
b-sides kind of singles and one of them
was rocking church remember rocking
chair amazing oasis song
anyway i said to him we were just sat on
a wall one night and i was like oh man i
love that song rocking chair and liam
went oh yeah how does that one go and i
said do you not remember anyone making
so many songs right now i can't remember
and i was like well i'm not gonna sing
it for you you actually sung it i'm not
gonna give you the bad impression and we
laughed about that but um that was cool
so you like you're from sheffield but
you like manchester u you enjoy living
there
oh yeah yeah man yeah yeah manchester uh
not quite as good as sheffield but you
know it's bigger more stuff going on
yeah yeah
that's good and how have you
done during this whole
topsy-turvy crazy pandemic time
um so i found a new hobby which is how i
actually heard about this podcast in the
first place
well we're playing a lot of uh d and d
online oh no and i first heard you guys
doing the uh the free black halflings
podcast oh yeah yeah
they were great i love them yeah they
were very cool a lot of passion for
there's a little
yeah there's a little rumor going around
you might try this uh
star trek sort of uh
game yeah yeah we're really trying that
and then
maybe maybe we'll get someone on here
yeah we can uh
that could be the dungeon master but i
guess if it's star trek they'd have to
be like the captain or something well i
don't know how it would work because
i've never played those games dom plays
them so he knows them but i know the
star trek universe always yes you're not
the dungeon master tim are you just one
of the people in it oh no i'm the i'm
the big guy oh no it's good for you man
oh could you maybe run over um star trek
one then
oh yeah well i've never seen star trek
but apart from that i'm sure i could
give it a go okay we'll try and face it
you're basically one of the crew members
yeah exactly you're like scotty street
yeah well tim it's been fascinating
talking to you thanks for telling us all
about lasers that was amazing
yes thanks for talking to you guys keep
up the good work or keep up the light
work
do you guys say that at work
is there any like laser-based jokes oh
yeah but i think uh yeah tomorrow
morning in my truck yeah you put that do
the staff and it have any kind of
is there any laser-based kind of
in-jokes
not off the top of my head
thanks for getting in touch and you're
the first person to kick off this whole
wacky work was it wacky work unless
unless people write in and give us a
better name for this segment it will be
wait wait it wasn't wacky was it john
johnson a minute ago
which is quite good tim it was great
talking to you
hey great talking to you guys as well
yeah thank you very much thanks a lot
tim look after yourself
cheers guys
bye
fantastic tom lasers we've all learned a
thing or two about lasers i did actually
and now we'll remember for the rest of
our life that the acronym for lasers is
love
and
sugar loving sugar
robert
loving sugar air rubber
uh yeah we all love a laser we found out
if it was hot i think that was the thing
that i wanted to know the most is when
it's made is it hot it is and he said
it'll burn my coat so that's good uh and
are used i mean there's a lot of people
making lasers in his place yeah so
there's a lot of people buying lasers
yeah dna that's what they mainly want be
something for us to think about as a
side hustle maybe do the podcast in the
morning
and then leave one of our cars here
carpool to a local factory
you make a hundred lasers i make 100
lasers we head home for dinner fantastic
let's think about it it's something to
think about though
well should we eat the world let's eat
the world our favorite moment i love the
[ __ ] and i'm actually hungry again i'm
hungry as well you're sitting there with
an apple trying to make me envious yeah
sorry about that here he is his johnny
clues thanks johnny clues hey thank you
jack quaffy thank you for the coffee
there josh that's how you guys say it
over in britain we might say coffee yes
but not here coffee
bring me a black coffee and put a bunch
of [ __ ] sugar in it like don't you
you want a bagel hey you got a bagel got
any maple syrup when you throw out in
the coffee cup throw it down the back of
my throat hey so this week i'm getting
to the stuff here right come on john
sorry for the swearing billy and dom eat
the world if there's any if there's any
parents at home that are like oh we like
this show but they shouldn't swear it's
not
billy and dom swearing it's these uh
new york cabbie guys yeah which we
should give names i think too i feel
like my guy has
don't know where this came from but i
think maga has a interchangeable girl or
boy name
such as
jean
billy
oh billy yeah there you go that billy
piper billy jean
not your lover right no you love him
okay just checking uh
okay can i be called denver dave
denver dave yeah but you're doing a
denver accent as as
a as a denver i'll show you again
hey bring me a bagel there you [ __ ]
hey yeah yeah he is from denver see
things to do in denver when you're dead
just lie down for eternity
so
this week we're doing well i've got to
stop that voice now this week we are
doing a classic biscuit
from the country of australia i believe
the tim tam now we had quite a lot of
tim tams during our employment in
new zealand on
the lord of the rings i mean do you want
to take a tim tam or two take what
dumber well and see the very first fact
that i've read here
it's actually
i'd i've always thought this about a tim
tam
i don't even know what you're going to
say go on because i've always thought
sometimes like a penguin biscuit did you
like a penguin biscuit would you hear
this the tim tam was invented by an
australian man named ian norris and
whilst he was in britain
he tried a penguin biscuit
which is a chocolate covered biscuit
with chocolate cream manufactured by
united biscuits right inspired by the
penguin biscuit norris wanted to make a
better one cheeky so by 1964 tim tams
were being manufactured by annettes in
australia and quickly gained popularity
the biscuits were named after a horse by
the same name which had won the 1958
kentucky derby wow who knew that
a penguin biscuit very popular when we
were kids yeah the interesting thing
about penguins is
they
had different colored wrappers yes but
it never changed the flavor of the
biscuit did it let's get us all this is
a chocolatey kind of blue green
yellow
we could just say
a rainbow
sing a rainbow
dad took your three lines to join them
so i was getting excited about the tim
tam trick as i like to call it we'll
talk you through this because you don't
know this no i don't this is this is uh
well first of all we should say the tim
tam was recommended by daniel
from
katikati
in new zealand i hope i didn't murder
that from oliver s in australia from
gary h in south australia from byron b
in australia and from my mate jackie
from uh new zealand who said the same
thing and the tim tam tip trick is like
this you get yourself a cup of tea or a
cup of coffee which we've got right now
i've got a coffee right here tom
you buy off both
narrow ends sesa
and you use the tim tam biscuit as a
straw what the heck
to suck up so now you're getting a
coffee chocolatey type of thing it can
get go all over the place you have to be
careful but should we try the tim tam so
we're basically going to use the tim tam
as a straw it's a straw can you also do
this with a penguin
not a real penguin i'd never do it with
a real penguin pay off its tail bait off
its beak just tastes like pilchards
would be no good uh i'm sure you can do
it with a with a uh
a penguin biscuit i'll bet that off
that's one handgun
for people who are bothered about the
the sound of us chewing
i'm threatening about
five inches from the mic
i was about two and a half feet away
then because i'm now getting worried
that people do not like the sound of my
mastication but i i find mastication
to be extremely important i'm gonna
taste the coffee make sure i don't burn
my tongue through my um tim tam straw
unfortunately due to the slap dash way
in which the tim thames and the coffee
were brought in by johnny clues
i'm having to stir my coffee with a pen
which i think is extremely unhygienic
and cruel to the pen
have you tried it yet yeah is it good
it's really good but it's not easy no
it's not easy well most tricks aren't
hang on like a bit no my thumb damn's
just melting
my thumb time's going dumb dumb oh yes
ah is it going in the car yeah it's gone
in the coffee
you've made a pig's ear of that
i had it
and then it just went i would have done
the same but when you said it i hoiked
my tim tam up where is it no i've shoved
it in my garb the whole thing the whole
thing
wow that is good now my mate jackie who
i saw yesterday said not only can you do
tea or cough and coffee yeah and hot
chocolate which i'm sure would be
fantastic for this but she said some
real wild cards out there do stuff like
apple juice and orange juice to get like
an orange chocolate taste type thing
and i said how is it and she said it's
not great i prefer the hot chocolate
sounds like she tried a lot of it oh
yeah she loves it she's never done it
with a gin and tonic
i'm not sure jackie get in touch if
you've done it with the gin and tonic
the tim tam that is
uh
more facts here the biscuit is currently
owned by the united states campbell soup
company campbell soup
for for 10 points
what artist
was famous for drawing campbell's soup
tins andy warhol and what is andy
warhol's arguably most famous quote
i love soup
no i love soup meat he says
i'll tell you and you'll be like oh yeah
that is i love soup meat cambog soup in
particular they probably did say that at
some point but i love soup meat
campbell's soup in particular the
chicken noodle
i think he liked the tomato soup more
than any other
andy wall is
probably more famously known for saying
everyone will be famous for 15 minutes
i didn't know that i was on the warhol
yeah
it was very smart
quite prophetic one of the first artists
who
who said well art doesn't
you know i'll do a painting like a
campbell's soup
and it's say it's mainly red
and then somebody wants to buy it and
they'll say no but i want it from a
living room and my color
scheme in the living room is blue he
said we'll do another one please don't
matter it's fine he's not an artist
who's like no that's what it is it's
great no i'll do whatever color you want
andy wahl seemed to be interested in
exploring the art form of
replication
right
so i'll do marilyn monroe once
but then like you said i'll i'll make it
yellow i'll make it blue i'll put four
of them next to each other i'll turn one
upside down that is my art form he's
brilliant he wore a wig right no
that was his real hair um you're
obsessed with people in wigs
well i'm losing my hair
i went to see someone to say to get a
professional opinion do you think i'm
losing my hair yeah would you say
he said i don't think you are losing
your hair any more than
you know normal yeah and he said which
this really like stopped me from
worrying
he took a mirror so that i could see all
that yeah and he said if your hair
stayed like this
would you be happy with it if you just
stay late and i said yeah and he said
well then just keep an eye on it and if
you start to see a massive difference
yeah
let's chat but
well he's probably trying to sell
something as well so if he's saying his
job if he's saying it's all right then
and if i start to if i get like a big
zinedine zidane ball patch
i'm definitely getting that hair thing
done are you yeah i've gone bold but i'm
just gonna let it happen yeah you're
embracing it and you suit it i'll just
shave it i don't suit it see there are
some people that i think suit john
malkovich looks great without hair joe
rogan looks great without hair
zinedine zidane looks brilliant without
hair i don't think i would you look
great with hair bob mortimer looks great
without hair
or with less hair
it's all about owning it isn't it and i
think
i would be just a bit self-conscious
about it but you don't want now
more facts for you here
i was halfway through that the biscuit
is currently owned by the us campbell
soup company which bought out our knots
in 2011 the actual ongoing product
developed for tim tams is still
australian based australian based mmm
this biscuit see in recent years
in recent years the appetite for new tim
tam varieties has boomed
starting with variations like what do
you hear this time
dark chocolate mint
white chocolate
and it's since going on to be even more
adventurous in its flavoring it doesn't
say what
give me
what you think would be an adventurous
flavor for a tim tam orange chocolate
yeah i would love an orange chocolate
one actually
then it'd be a mix between a penguin and
a viking right
i'll tell you what else is good with
chocolate is uh the fruit or the berry
which is also a fruit raspberry rice you
could do a raspberry chocolate but
coconut lovely would you like a coconut
tim tam i'd love that but i'll tell you
what i'm going to open up a hornet's
nest here oh wait you hear that nest of
vipers go on dump
white chocolate
some people chocolate well
i mean first of all
that is not chocolate
this is not associated with the cocoa
bean oh right there's no cocoa bean in
it you can't you shouldn't really be
able to call that chocolate hey what is
it i thought it was some sort of
white paste sugar did you did you like a
milky bar i like a milky bar do you know
the whole the whole song from the ad
i'll start it if you can finish the
milky market is strong and tough and
only the best is good enough the
milkiest milk the whites is spa nestles
the goodness that's in milky bars
there was a tiny little bit of milk in
milky bars which is the way that they
sold it but i don't think it's healthy i
did so give them their credit i did
enjoy
the advert for a milky bar it's a tiny
little cowboy yeah in a in a
town
where
like stuff is going on hey like chicago
yeah there's a lot of little cahoots
people people like people in cahoots
with each other yeah these guys and this
saloon
getting thrown out into the mud yeah
we're all fighting there you pull out
your sick shooter right i'm shooting you
in the face and then
the milky bar kid shows up hey
everyone's a grown-up he's like six or
seven yeah he's got little glasses
little round glasses over there stop
messing around you gotta put your guns
away and they go oh [ __ ] it's the milky
bar kid now in real life
he would get battered wouldn't why did i
get shot and put in a shallow grave
though yeah a tiny little grave the
milky bark but great adverts but white
chocolate come on there's no chance i
forgot my tim tam had went into my
coffee there
and it touched my top lip and i got free
because i just watched jaws the other
day as you know so there was a miniature
shark in your coffee cup maybe how does
your mind work
anyway
campbell's soup company previously
launched milky by our tim tams in the
united states but did not find initial
success probably because the biscuit
market in the united states was flooded
because there's a lot of biscuits to
choose from in the united states what
lake
well you've got your uh
little
jiminy biscuits
uh lovely little jiminy biscuits
little jiminy biscuits and then you got
your uh what the hell got cotton cream
candy uh cookie cut cream love a cotton
cream candy cookie then there's the uh
there's a tiny little
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] flapjack
like a [ __ ] flapjack
those things are fantastic sorry if
anyone at home is offended by f-bombs i
am too but it's not me doing it it's um
gene i think my guy's called g it's gene
gene and jen for dave and jennifer dave
anyway the campbell suit company did a
new attempt to launch tim tams in 2016
right and it has been very successful
and grabbed media attention which is a
very vague fact
so campbell's soup company now appears
to be
is
now appears to be taking advantage of
its spreading fame and it is confident
that a potential placement in walmart
will take the brand nationwide i don't
know if we should be advertising walmart
on this show well if tim tam gets in
there they're not paying i'll tell you
what campbell's soup will be over the
moon
oh god house oh it's quite sweet that
belch because it was a tim tam do you
want to give it some scores let's give
it some tim terms isn't tam a very
popular name for an old man in scotland
yeah
if you don't know someday you could
maybe call them tam and is that santa is
that
tom that's just thomas yeah right
like the um
biblical name thomas but it's tam right
strangely isn't that how things could
take my late uncle george
who has not been around for a long time
he went up
he was actually called john but for some
reason why george i don't know
that doesn't matter never really got to
the bottom of that
if anyone knows out there why my uncle
george was called john probably my dad
oh my mom oh what was your aunt's name
is she still around yeah a few men is
there still around georgie's wife
no george never married
we'll just leave that
um scores on the doors what's the score
for the tim tam tom flavor i like it i
actually like it i
i don't remember it being that tasty
i enjoyed that i had too and i would
have a third but i'm watching my figure
uh you can watch it for me
gonna give that
an 8.7
for flavor that's very good because i
felt exactly the same as you dumb i
don't remember them being that good
quite rich yummy and a nice chocolate
not doesn't feel like a lot of
preservatives there might be i don't
know
but
i'm going to give that
an 8.2
lovely
aesthetic aesthetics
of the packet itself all the biscuit
there's i like the way they're presented
in a little drawer like that yeah that's
nice isn't it that's good i like how the
chocolate covers but yet hints at what's
within yeah the middle section
it's a classic biscuit shape
aesthetics all around
it's a seven that's quite good i would
like the the chocolate seems a little
like it's powdered
or i'd like it slightly darker slightly
darker i hear you on that one i'm gonna
say
six point eight
i've seen nicer biscuits
what would you what is the nicest
looking biscuit you've ever seen the
nicest biscuit
weirdest you know a weird one
a walnut whip
is that a biscuit no it's more of a
confectionary
but that who thought of that strange
well make it like a whip shape and stick
a walnut on it yeah it's like a
miniature
circus tent
it's like a volcano yeah it's like
vesuvius itself yeah vesuvius erupted
onto the city of pompeii
that's the noise it made thank you
um the nicest biscuit i mean
it's hard to argue with the jammy dodger
wow
if you don't know what a jammy dodger is
for anyone not in uh the uk
spherical biscuit circle
the
vanilla colored
slightly off-white color yeah yeah
with a gem circle right in the middle
and i think it's got a little bit of uh
icing under the jam
icing denture
now but sometimes and the jam will come
through a heart shape right at the very
center of the aforementioned circle yeah
when i was a kid i used to like to lick
my index finger and stick it in the jam
so the jammy dodgy would stick to my
finger yeah so that i could kind of
pretend to be like a
kind like an et with a with a biscuit on
the end of my finger i go over to my
mates and be like look at me dodge your
finger no not your finger
kids are weirdo yeah what's your
favorite aesthetic of a biscuit
you know what i i used to love it was a
breakaway
that's an awful looking biscuit no
because i'll tell you what i used to do
a boring kicker yeah but you take you
take the paper bit off and then you're
left with foil if you'll remember i do
rub the foil gently
and the very shape of the top
of the um
would would then transfer onto the foil
what would you do with that then i would
very gently remove the foil
take it off so it still leaves the
imprint of the aforementioned
coin rubbing in the old days
i would eat the breakaway
virtually
in a winner
and then
i would be left with not just the memory
yeah but also
and
and tin foil
could you then re-fashion the shape of a
breakaway
and jokingly pass it off to a mate yes
do you want a break and they go oh you
bastard there's no breakaway in there
really it's just air
that's great although
yeah okay fine i'm not gonna get into it
i just i was going to say that's a great
trick but is it really a nice looking
biscuit but yeah
fine
fine oh wait usefulness
usually no
i've never known a cookie you can use as
a straw before and as you know we're not
using straws anymore because uh turtles
it kills turtles yeah etc
so i think having a another form of
straw and a one in chocolate form is a
good idea but as you saw it's pretty
much only a oneness draw yeah we'll just
go straight in there i've still got half
a tim because i'm thinking i've got two
tim tams
but i haven't really cause wonder i'm
still in here that's a tree do you know
the difference between a turtle and a
tortoise yep come on uh turtle lives in
the water a tortoise lives in your
imagination
yeah almost entirely right yeah a turtle
either lives or spends the predominant
the the dominant part of their life in
or around water predominantly i don't
care i love it they have a much closer
relationship to water they either live
in water their entire life or lay their
eggs in water or make your water kind of
tortoise will drink water but his land
dwelling in the united states states all
tortoises terrapins and turtles are
called turtles and that is wholly
incorrect
thanks you know like a galapagos yeah
tortoise yeah in the united states they
go oh look at the size of that turtle
that's not a turtle but let's say for
instance i was in the desert a few years
ago and i saw a tortoise
would would people in america call that
turtle and i think
john
if you saw a tortoise in the desert
would you say
say you were with your
your fiance would you say
excuse me
there's a turtle or there's a tortoise
well first off uh i you guys say
tortoise really uh yeah we say tortoise
you guys say
toys
yeah uh i would yeah i'd probably say
it's a turtle
i'm sorry now i feel like a fool it's
fine i do actually think the um
teenage mutant ninja turtles probably
created quite a
mess with them oh yeah because the
teenage mutant ninja turtles who live
down in the sewers so they have a little
bit of a relationship with running water
yeah we've got kind of a hybrid yeah
to land tortoise and i think it it and
also ninja and ninja they created a real
mess to what remember the name of their
teacher
uh it was a rat it was a rat lives in
the sewer don't know they love [ __ ]
splinter splinter yeah
and our friend sean aston voices one of
the turtles is that right yeah in the
movies uh in the tv show i had no idea
there you go a man of many talents we've
run out of time again what we need to
wrap it up we did we took too much time
wait a minute we need we need to finish
first with them um
usefulness quickly usefulness on the tim
tam it's great as a straw
apart from that it's a good biscuit it
will melt in your hand i did get some
melted
usefulness
i think you could maybe make a cake and
sprinkle sometimes definitely make it
good
inspired cake then you could freeze them
ice cream you could freeze it and maybe
smash it up and then sprinkle it on top
of your ice cream i think there's quite
a few uses for this i'm gonna i'm gonna
give it a a solid
8.2 for usefulness that's good for a
cookie yeah i'm going to give it a 7.5
okay we're in the right ball park that's
it we definitely run out of time guys if
you want to get in touch with us we'd
love
that if you do a job that you think we'd
be fascinated to learn about if there's
a song you want us to listen to if
there's a food item get in touch with us
the friendship onion at castmedia.com
that's casper the k and also if you want
to send us one of those voicemails you
can do that on
speakpipe.com forward slash the
friendship onion also we have a spotify
playlist yes we do the friendship onion
where we put all of the songs that we
listen to on that be aware there are a
lot of pretenders out there so you need
to find the official one i think that's
a rate review and subscribe to our
podcast for why
just to make us happy yeah so we can
make more yeah
and we'll see you guys
oh god tim tams next week
see ya toodles
[Music]